[MUSIC PLAYING]
PIYUSH MALIK: Good
morning, everyone.
How's everyone doing?
My name is Piyush Malik.
I'm a Vice President at
springML, a premier partner
to Google Cloud in the area
of machine learning and data
analytics.
And today we will be talking
about predictive maintenance
and IoT and ML.
I'll be joined by my
colleagues, Manuel
from springML and
Prashant from Google,
and we'll go through this.
But just before
we get started, I
want to get a sense
of the audience here.
And it's a bright
light from the back.
So by a show of
hands, how many of you
are data scientists, machine
learning specialists?
All right.
How many are IoT specialists?
OK, great.
And how many are C-level or
execs or business development
guys?
Oh, OK.
All right.
Good.
Good mix.
So I would say
right in the middle.
33% each.
So I think we should have
enough for all of you
in this presentation.
Get it to advance.
Do I need to point to
something to get it to advance?
It's not advancing.
SPEAKER: Here, I'll
check it for you.
PIYUSH MALIK: So while
the clicker gets to work--
so predictive
maintenance and IoT.
Now today the agenda is--
we'll start with some
industry scenarios
to get everybody level set
on predictive maintenance.
Then we'll talk about
how Google Cloud IoT
Core is a platform for
predictive maintenance.
Then we will come
to the specific demo
that we've got for
oil and gas industry--
a solution that we've built
using these components.
And thirdly, we will
come to a client case
where we'll talk about how
we've done something like this,
and how we can put to practice.
And finally, we'll get to the
future and what lies ahead.
SPEAKER: We're going
to have to [INAUDIBLE]..
PIYUSH MALIK: OK.
All right, so this is the
agenda that we went through.
The clicker is not working.
OK, so in the area
of asset management--
no?
OK.
All right.
Just by show of
hands, how many of you
think this hypothesis is true?
Everything needs maintenance.
All right?
OK, good.
Hold that thought and
we'll come back to it.
Now, typically in
industry, heavy equipment
has a lifespan of anywhere
between 30 to 60 years, right?
And it's very difficult
to replace this equipment,
but if the breakdown
happens, it leads
to loss of productivity, loss of
profit, and so on and so forth.
Now how do you avoid
this costly down time?
Of course, you'll
say maintenance.
Now, another thing that
managers deal in manufacturing
is the operational
equipment efficiency.
And the legacy industry
assets have been in practice
for 30, 40 years.
Now, there are techniques that
have been followed till now,
which are time-based, and
they basically use statistics
from the past runs,
and they compile those
and make a best guess at
how to prevent the problems.
Now let's take a couple
of industry scenarios.
I'm assuming all of you
travel by air, right?
Now, can someone
tell me how many
components this
particular engine has?
This is a Boeing 747.
Any guesses out there?
Shout it out.
AUDIENCE: 1,000.
AUDIENCE: 60,000.
PIYUSH MALIK: Very close.
So about 25,000.
And this particular engine
and this particular flight
typically generates a
terabyte of data per flight.
Now, there are sensors in
all these 25,000 components
in the engine, and if they
could talk to each other,
and if those sensors
could be analyzed,
that is the heartbeat
that we need to listen to
and we need to avoid
catastrophic situations.
And of course, I
don't know about you,
but I have spent
many hours sitting
on the tarmac waiting for
the maintenance person
to come and fix the
problem in the aircraft.
I'm sure many of you can
relate to it as well.
So let's move onto an oil
and gas production rig.
These are massive equipment.
Whether it's at the
land or in the ocean,
they need to have some goals
to meet production output,
as well as it needs
to be safe operations.
So human lives are at stake,
and environmental regulations
are also important.
So each of these rigs also
has about 30,000 components.
But today, less
than 1% of that data
is being used to make decisions.
We need to change that.
Let's move to
manufacturing industry.
Same scenario.
A lot of complex operations.
A lot of components.
Now these
automations-- and as we
are getting into the world
of robotics and increased
automation, this scenario
will be even more important.
You cannot afford to have
a manufacturing line stop
in between.
So the best way is to optimize
this by keeping workers safe,
and avoid costly shutdowns,
and prevent disruptions.
So again, maintenance is key.
So having established
that, we did
some study of various analysts
and various industry bodies,
and this is what they found.
About 40% of preventive
maintenance costs
are spent on assets with
negligible impact on uptime.
30% of preventive maintenance
are carried out too frequently,
which are not needed.
And 45% of maintenance
efforts are ineffective.
What does this tell us?
This tells us that
time-based approach is not
going to work for the future.
And we need a
condition-based monitoring.
And at the same
time, as we know,
there are components
which talk to each other.
We need to be able
to harness that data
and have the ability to
not only store, but also
analyze the data on the edge.
So to summarize the
business benefits
of predictive
maintenance, I think
we've established different
industries need it.
And again, whether
it is a Fortune
or whether it is a
McKinsey, all these studies
point to the various
elements here
that, by using
predictive maintenance,
you can do a lot better with
your maintenance activities
and keep your equipment up.
You can reduce the maintenance
costs by up to 25%.
You can eliminate breakdowns
by 70%, and so on and so forth.
So I will also say that you are
able to give the benefit back
to your shareholders by
using predictive maintenance
for the C-level execs
out here in the audience.
Now, it's no strange news
to you that our world is
interconnected, and
some of the studies
that have been
done talk about how
there would be more than 220
billion devices with sensors.
Gartner says 20.4 billion
devices are connected today,
and by 2020, there will
be 50 billion devices.
But if only 1% of
savings by using IoT
is applied in oil and gas,
they could save $90 billion.
Think about the impact this has.
And overall IoT market
is a $3 trillion market.
Now this is a perfect segue into
talking about Cloud IoT Core.
This is a product which is
a fully-managed platform
for producing
insights from sensors
coming at a very rapid pace.
Hundreds of thousands of
events happening in real time--
we are able to analyze that
using GCP and, specifically,
Cloud IoT Core.
And using predictive
techniques as opposed
to time-based maintenance
can definitely
result in savings as well as
the safety of the operators.
And there are certain
features here.
I want to mention here
there are two components.
There's a device
gateway, and there
are abilities to process
this data in real time.
And there are some more features
that Google today announced,
so for that, I would like to
invite Prashant onstage to talk
about them.
Prashant?
PRASHANT DHINGRA:
Thanks, Piyush.
Hi.
My name is Prashant Dhingra.
I work as a machine
learning lead at Google.
As Piyush mentioned,
Cloud IoT Core
is a fully-managed service.
This is an entry point to
ingest data from Cloud IoT
and then you can apply machine
learning or data processing
component.
However, there is
a need to do data
processing where the data
exists, which is on the edge.
So there is a research from
IDC that 40% of the data
needs to be processed
where it originated from.
And there are six billion
devices get added every day.
So there are a number
of reasons why you need
to process data at the edge.
So latency and bandwidth
is the primary reason.
For example, if you are doing
fraud detection on a credit
card, you want to
determine the fraud
as someone is swiping the card.
So there is no time left to
take the data from credit card
and take it to the edge,
or take it to the Cloud
and then do the prediction.
So there is a latency
requirement in many scenarios
where it is important to do
the prediction at the edge.
Similarly, if you have a data
in machinery or in aircraft
and ships, sometimes there
are latency requirements
that require immediate action.
Bandwidth is also another issue.
So if you are doing predictive
maintenance on a ship,
sometimes the ships are
in the sea and many times
during the wartime, they do
not have the right bandwidth
or connectivity.
So there is a requirement
or a compliance requirement
that prediction should happen
even if there is no network
connectivity.
There are privacy issues
also, like some of the data
is not safe to transmit
over the networks.
That's another benefit of doing
the prediction on the edge.
And as I mentioned,
connectivity might be an issue.
Like when in a
machinery, the machines
are not always connected.
Ships or aircraft are
not always connected.
And there are cost
benefits also.
If you can do the
prediction on an edge,
you can save sending
all the data to a cloud.
So these were the
driving factors
that Google took into
account and today they
announced ML on Edge.
So in future, you will be
able to do data processing,
as well as you will be able
to do the machine learning on
as device.
Even before today, there
were component availables,
but they were not
managed component.
For example, there's
a component called
TensorFlow Lite that takes
your machine learning model.
You can compress the
machine learning model
and make it as smaller,
and you can deploy it
on an edge device.
So even today, you can do it.
But from tomorrow on, what
it will become much easier
for you, because there
will be a managed service.
And that managed service
is called Cloud IoT Edge.
It has two pieces.
It has Edge ML
and Edge IoT Core.
So earlier we discussed
Cloud IoT is a managed
service on a cloud, but
Edge ML and Edge IoT Core
will exist on your
devices, and you
will be able to
run it on Android
Things or any Linux-based
operating system.
So you might have also
heard about Edge TPUs.
So I just wanted to call out
the difference between the two.
Edge TPUs is a chip-based
hardware device,
and the Cloud IoT Edge
is a software stack,
so they work together.
So in a Cloud IoT
Edge, you can decide
to do data processing
or machine learning
using CPU, GPUs, or TPUs.
So if you have a requirement
where you need to use TPUs,
you can use Edge
TPUs to do prediction
on very complex model.
So your overall architecture
will look like that.
You will do the
Edge ML on a device,
and then you will take that
data, take it to Cloud.
You will do the training
there on the aggregated data,
you will build a model, and
deploy it on various devices.
This is a more complex version
of the previous ML lifecycle.
So which component you will use?
You will use Edge ML and
Edge IoT Core on a device.
Cloud IoT Core is for
connectivity of device,
and you can use IoT
function or Pub/Sub
to aggregate the data or
Dataflow to process the data.
And then you can store the
data into a Bigtable, BigQuery,
and once you have
stored the data,
you can do training using
Cloud Machine Learning.
So this will be an
end-to-end architecture.
And using this, you
will be able to build
powerful predictive maintenance
model, which you can run it
on a cloud as well as you can
deploy it on an Edge device.
That's all, Piyush.
PIYUSH MALIK: All right.
PRASHANT DHINGRA: Thanks a lot.
PIYUSH MALIK: Thank you.
Thank you, Prashant.
This is awesome.
I mean, we got the latest
information coming out
of Google from this
morning, and we
were able to incorporate
during the presentation.
So that's awesome.
Now lets talk about a solution
that we at springML have
built using IoT Core and ML.
And what are the problems that--
again, going back to the
predictive maintenance
scenario.
If somebody has to
maintain equipment,
they've got to keep spare parts.
Right?
If you have too much of
spare parts available,
that's like capital
bound, or wasted capital.
You want to optimize on that.
And if you don't have the
right component available
when a machine
breakdown happens,
then again, there is a
loss of productivity.
So how do you get around this?
And this is a solution
we will show how,
and we'll give you
a demo as well, how
it brings it together.
So as we have been
talking about,
sensors in the components
in the machines talk.
All we have to do is
listen to the machines.
The machines are telling
you when they need help.
Not time-based.
It's not like your car has
an auto meter of 10,000 miles
and it needs oil change.
No, not anymore.
Or for that matter, any boat
that is traveling in sea,
and it needs change
of an engine,
because it has run
for so many hours.
It is the components
which look at wear
and tear, look at temperature,
humidity, and so on, so forth.
And this solution
brings all of that
together using the concept
of remaining useful life.
And again, we used
Cloud IoT Core,
and the sensor data was read in
a secure fashion in real time,
and we executed machine learning
model to get predictions.
And this is a
simplified architecture.
It might look a bit--
let me just simplify it for you.
The gateway-- the
sensor data comes in.
Cloud Pub/Sub, which can handle
lots of events per second
in hundreds of
thousands, and it is
able to process the data
through the pipeline
and various components for
either storing or doing
analytics on the Cloud,
and it can be deployed
for the users [INAUDIBLE].
So with that, of course,
this benefit of this solution
is it provides deep
understanding of your asset
performance in real time, and
proactive alerts are sent out.
So with that, I want to
invite my colleague Manuel
to give a demo of the solution
that we built. There you go.
MANUEL AMUNTAGUEI: Thank you.
Thank you.
Can I get the
slides back please?
Thank you.
So I'm going to walk you through
a demo we built around the oil
refinery industry, and
it's to showcase IoT Core
and also how it fits in the GCP.
It turns out, one thing that
was interesting in building
this demo was to
understand the big picture.
It turns out IoT Core is
actually not the bottleneck.
It works really well.
It's very easy to use.
You plug-in your sensors
and you get your data.
The problem is you end
up with a deluge of data.
There's just too much--
an avalanche of data.
And how do you deal with it?
And that's when the whole GCP
pipeline starts making sense.
Especially if you want to
run IoT models at scale,
you need all the
pieces that fit in
after IoT Core have
to be able to scale,
have to be able to
reduce your data,
have to be able to deal with
it so you can learn about it.
So first off,
before I go to demo,
let me just talk about
some of the challenges.
You need enough historical
data to run these models.
In our case, we're
looking at time series.
It's like survival analysis.
So you'll need enough
data from the time
you turn the machine on to
the time the machine dies.
You need to have enough
of these historical cases
in order to run these
kind of models--
to train these kind of models
to learn what features indicates
a failure.
And if it's not time
series-- if it's binary,
you'll need enough
of your whatever
the minority cases
in order to learn.
If it's
multi-classification, you'll
need to have enough
of each class
to be able to properly
train a model.
And that's nothing to
do with IoT, right?
That's just machine
learning in general.
Same thing with selecting
the right model.
Because we're talking
about big data,
we're talking about
big data streaming,
you've got to find models
that work in the Cloud
that you can mount easily
in Cloud MLE that can handle
this huge amount of throughput.
And I'll talk about
this after the demo.
And of course, what
is your end product?
Is it going to be a dashboard?
An alerting system?
Does it feed into
some other tool?
So all these things have to be
thought of as a big picture.
The IoT is more than
just the IoT Core.
Its a lot of different pieces.
And can I have my
machine now please?
So here I'm in Google
Cloud and I have
Virtual Machine ready to go.
And I'm going to simulate
some machine data.
And I'll talk about where that
data came from in a minute.
We're going to wait.
It's going to
generate two engines,
and it's going to assimilate a
bunch of sensors per machine.
I will give it a minute.
I mean, a couple of
seconds till it starts.
There it is.
There it comes in.
And now I can go to the demo.
And we have a website.
There it is.
So yeah.
So the two points-- so you could
have 1,000 of these oil rigs.
So each green dot on
the map is an oil rig.
We have two just for this demo--
North Dakota and Kansas.
And I can click on any of them.
I'll choose the one in Kansas.
And then you see a
green dot that appears.
Here.
I'll try to use a laser.
A green dot that appears.
You could have multiple
machines on this rig.
Again, for the
simplicity of this demo,
we're just using one.
And here we click on it.
And in this case, just for
the closure of this demo,
we're building a dashboard.
So the top part, you
have the predictive side.
So this is what the engine
learned, and now it's
saying that this
engine currently
has plenty of life left.
So normally these engines
would break down in years.
Of course here we're doing
it in minutes for the demo.
But as long as it's in
the green zone, it's safe.
If it gets to the
yellow, that's when
you would fire off alerts--
text or whatever
needs to be done,
or a temporary turn down
a machine to swap a piece.
When it's in danger
zone, it's just bad.
So the second level here, these
are the real-time indicators.
It tells you basically
what the machine--
the ML model is using.
This is the same data,
so we're presenting
real-time data like cable
tension, oil temperature,
et cetera, et cetera.
That's what the model
is using to predict
the above bar, whether it's
healthy or not healthy,
or in danger.
And lower we have a bunch
of historical indicators,
and that's just recording
the data through time
so that we can see how it's
progressing through time
and before failure.
And I am going to
go back to the map.
And I'll bring it back when
it's in a yellow state.
But can I get the
slides back please?
Thank you.
So high-level-- there's
a deeper view later on.
But a very high level, you
have the Python simulator that
is pumping data into IoT Core--
so these are the sensors--
into IoT Core.
IoT Core then messages
it out to Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is this massive
message queuing system,
and publishes it out, and we
have Dataflow as a subscriber.
So when you have a
subscriber, you're
always guaranteed
to get every packet
at least once from Pub/Sub.
That's the guarantee
it does-- the contract.
And Dataflow can do a lot.
Here we're just
scratching the surface
of what Dataflow can do.
It can do aggregation, it
can do data transformation,
it can do MapReduce--
that kind of stuff.
So these are tools.
All these tools are
designed to scale and handle
huge amounts of data.
So it's not just
IoT Core anymore.
It's everything in
the pipeline that
needs to be able to handle
what you're throwing at it.
And Dataflow will
transform the data,
pass it to the Regressor model--
here the deep neural network
regressor--
to get a prediction,
and all that data
is stored in BigQuery.
And BigQuery-- massive
data warehouse.
I was reading you could
query 35 billion rows of data
with no indexes in seconds.
And it just-- it's funny because
we work a lot with BigQuery,
and you're typing select star
or select whatever field from,
and it just feels like you're
querying your local database
on your machine, and
you're like, eh, whatever.
Right?
It ran.
It's good.
When in reality,
what's happening behind
is it could be querying
thousands of machines
all around the
world, and it just
feels like it's
your local machine.
So that's a phenomenal tool.
Great to work with.
And I need to talk a bit
about the data we're using.
So we're using this dataset
called Modular Aero-Propulsion
System Simulations--
MAPSS.
It's open source made
available by NASA.
And these are turbofan
engines from life to death,
and they made that public.
So we are simulating
our data based on that,
and that was very useful
for us, because we're
talking about real machine
data with a series of sensors.
And there are 22 in total.
And here you would train
your model for IoT,
just like you would
train any other model.
You'll figure out if your
features are significant.
You'll figure out
variable importance.
And for example,
in this case, we
found a bunch that were
not helping the model.
We threw them out,
and we just kept
the ones that were of use,
just like you would model
anything-- any other model.
In terms of the models we used--
so we tried a whole bunch.
This is time series data.
So we tried LSTMs, we tried
Wide and Deep Regressor.
It's a very popular model that
is part of the Estimator API.
But in the end, the estimator
DNNRegressor was the simplest.
Really transparent model,
and it worked really well.
And I'll say a few words
here about the Estimator API,
because this is really
huge in TensorFlow.
Most of the TensorFlow
code you'll see online
may not fit easily into the
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
And when you're talking
about modeling at scale,
or predicting at
scale, you've got
to make sure that your model
can be distributed to thousands
of machines if needs be.
So you need to comply
with the way Cloud MLE can
handle your TensorFlow model.
And if you follow the
Estimator-- the API--
you'll automatically
get inherited classes.
The deployment classes,
the train and test classes,
all these things.
And even if you want
to do a more complex,
it does have a bunch
of built-in models
like DNNRegressor
and a Wide and Deep.
But if you need to do really
complex custom models,
you can still inherit from the
base class of TF Estimator,
and you will benefit
from the exact functions
you need to be able to
deploy to the Cloud.
So can I have my machine
back for a minute please?
So just want to highlight that.
So now both of these
machines are in alert state.
So this would be when you
would start sending out
SMSs, texts, update dashboards--
you know, fire off alarms.
Can I have the
slides back please?
And eventually
it'll turn to red,
but I think I don't need
to [INAUDIBLE] on that.
And I'll talk about a
scoring in a minute,
so I'm going leave that one.
So here is how you would
call this Regressor model--
part of the Estimator API.
It's super simple.
You just call it, and
all you need really
is just give it
your hidden units.
And I think even
will do a default
to hidden units for you.
But you can say how
many hidden layers
you want-- the sizes you want.
Here we are calling
in the optimizer.
You don't even have to do
that if you don't want to,
but it's nice, because
you can pass it
your L1 and your learning rate.
But you wouldn't
even need to do that.
So that permits you to not worry
too much about mucking around
with this stuff and think
about what your business use
case is-- what's really
important, right?
Because these things
work, they're well done,
you can trust them, and they do
expose a series of parameters
that you need,
but you don't have
to worry too much
above the rest.
And this really
frees us to say, OK,
we know it's from
the Estimator API.
It's going to be able to
be mounted in Cloud MLE.
Fine.
And you can move on and think
about what your business is all
about.
In terms of score, I'm going to
just briefly talk about this.
We've got a root mean
squared error of 45.
That means there's about 350
on average cycles per engine
in our demo data.
And that means we're plus or
minus correct on 45 cycles.
And Prashant was just
telling me that they
worked on this model
and this dataset more,
and they even got
it down to five.
So more future engineering.
You can work this
number a lot lower.
But this was in line with the
papers on that dataset we saw,
so we were satisfied
just for the demo's sake.
OK, so here is a more
precise schema of the model.
So you see the Python is passing
the simulated data to the IoT
Core.
IoT Core is passing
it to Pub/Sub.
Pub/Sub is passing
it to Dataflow.
So this is where we see more
precision than the other chart
are showing you before.
Dataflow can do a lot of things.
It can be like your data
manager, your choreographer
here in this case.
So it's doing multiple things.
It's preparing the data
so that you can pass it
to the DNNRegressor model,
which is mounted in Google Cloud
through Cloud MLE.
So this is the prediction.
And it's also passing the
real-time data to BigQuery.
BigQuery, as I mentioned, is
an industrial-strength data
warehouse.
It's a bottomless pit.
You can just keep
throwing data at it.
It will just distribute
in the background.
So that's when you start
seeing these more sophisticated
models.
It's no more you have one
model yielding a prediction.
Now you have many
models, and it could
have many models-- many
different processes handling
the data.
And the output is everything.
It's going to be BigQuery is
going to give our visualization
layer.
That dashboard I
was showing you is
going to give the prediction.
That was the top part.
It's also going to give
the real-time data.
So because we're pumping
all the data into BigQuery,
you just take whatever features
you have, the latest timestamp,
and those are your real-time
values for your features
of whatever machine
you're looking at.
And also historical data, right?
And all that can be
queried in BigQuery.
So BigQuery is actually yielding
three different values--
the predictions,
the current values,
and the historical data.
So pretty powerful tool.
Very easy to work with.
And in terms of
training, I'll close this
by saying a few things.
If an engine is going
to break down on average
every three years,
maybe every six months
you could retrain, right?
If the model you
feel is drifting,
you could also build some
continuous online modeling
where it's continually
reassessing the data.
The only caveat, and
something that we all
have to think about when
we're building these models,
is if you retrain
on a model where
you have done something on--
you have taken action
on a prediction--
your data becomes tainted.
Not tainted, but
it's just different.
So you need to
segregate what data
you have taken an
action on because
of a prediction from your model,
versus what was left alone.
So if you're doing
another round,
you probably would have
to do two separate models,
or just choose which one
you want to work with.
And this is just a quick
recap over what we saw.
So this is in a healthy,
healthy machine.
Everything looks like
it's in the green.
We have the historical values.
And now here we
have it is broken.
This is in the
danger zone, and we
can see we have some
extremes, and that's
what the model would use.
We started with 17
features, so there
are more than just those four.
And that's it.
I'm going to pass
it back to Piyush.
Here, let me go back.
PIYUSH MALIK: Oh, this is good.
MANUEL AMUNTAGUEI: Good.
PIYUSH MALIK: Thank you, Manuel.
So hopefully you got a sense
of how we built the solution.
And now coming to real
life client projects--
obviously as I
told you, springML
is an application provider and
a specialized partner to Google
in machine learning
and data analytics.
So this is how we execute
projects with client problems.
Essentially we want to make
sure we understand the business
problem, so we heavily
partner with the clients.
After the understanding
of their business domain
and putting the data scientists
and data engineers together,
we do the step of
data preparation.
And as Manuel alluded
to, data preparation
is the toughest part.
And in fact, data
manging or data
wrangling as he called
it-- data scientists
tend to spend more than 75% to
80% of their time doing that.
And once the data
is prepped, we've
got to determine
the right features.
And as we discussed,
there are ML models
that have to be built, and
they have to be trained,
and then they have
to be deployed.
So to do this and
bring to life, I
will talk about a
real client's case.
And the client is a leader
in the telematics industry.
One of the largest users
of Google Cloud Platform
in Canada.
And as it so happens,
I have Mike Branch,
the VP of Data and Analytics
from Geotab with me.
Mike, why don't you
come onstage with me?
Please welcome.
MIKE BRANCH: All right.
So--
[APPLAUSE]
PIYUSH MALIK: Thank you.
Thank you.
So Mike, as you saw how
we executed on the project
partnering with
Google and yourself,
we went through
this project maybe
almost more than
six months back.
And we just
published, by the way,
a case study on this last
week, and that's the reason
why Mike is here right now.
And the problem that we had
in this particular project
was to find out what's
the utilization.
How in particular, their
fleet is being used.
But before I get
into that, I would
want Mike to say
what Geotab does,
and what's so special
about this project.
MIKE BRANCH: Yeah, absolutely.
So Geotab-- first of all, we're
the second-largest provider
of telematics in
the world right now.
So we track about 1.2
million commercial vehicles,
and the raw data that's
coming into our ecosystem
is about three billion raw
records on a daily basis.
So the device plugs into
the onboard diagnostic port
of a vehicle, tracks
everything from harsh braking,
erratic driving events, seat
belt buckled, unbuckled,
engine RPM--
the likes.
But the biggest
challenge with all
of this data with
1.2 million vehicles
is how do you figure out how
the vehicles are driving?
If I'm going to
benchmark my customers
and benchmark them for
productivity, or for idling,
or for fuel usage,
fuel economy, I
need to do it based on the
vocation of the vehicle, not
the industry that
the vehicle is in.
Industry just
doesn't make sense.
It's how you drive
your vehicle, and what
is its purpose in life.
So that was the
difficult challenge
that we had when we brought
in the guys at Google
and the guys at springML
and they gave us a hand.
And that's important for us
from a benchmarking perspective.
But then also from
the perspective
of understanding-- if
I'm looking at smart city
applications.
What does freight movement
look like within a city?
So that's where these guys were
able to really, really shine
and give us a hand here.
PIYUSH MALIK: Right.
So again, look at
the slide out here,
which outlines what the problem
was, and what we delivered,
and multiple statistical models,
and using machine learning.
Again, this slide
says 1.1 million.
Obviously they have grown since
the time we did the project.
So he said 1.2 million,
so I stand corrected here.
And there's a quote
from him, as well.
So thank you very much
for being a customer.
And I appreciate you
coming out here, Mike.
MIKE BRANCH: No problem.
Thank you very much.
PIYUSH MALIK: All right.
So obviously, you saw so
far the application of IoT
and machine learning and
a real-life client study.
What's in the future?
As we think about the future, we
can talk about a lot of things
that we can do with
IoT and ML together,
whether it is in the area
of manufacturing, domain
of manufacturing, or putting
automation, robotics,
or whether it's transforming
service industry
or building smarter
cities, as Mike alluded to.
So I'll throw some light
on a couple of these cases,
and then we'll have some
time for Q&A towards the end.
So just take an example
of the service industry.
Using the concepts that
we have talked about--
predictive maintenance,
IoT, and ML--
they can be different
business models.
So one of them is
asset as a service.
So instead of selling equipment,
you're just offering capacity.
Just as the software is a
service, asset is a service.
And where you are able to
predict time to failure,
you are able to find whether
the machine has degraded,
find anomalies there.
And thereby you can improve the
profitability of your warranty
deals.
Like there are companies
which specialize in this.
Now this has also
an added advantage
of moving from capex to opex,
and the financial CFOs actually
love this concept whereby
you are able to capitalize.
Another model is the
usage based insurance.
Now this is where the behavior
of the driver comes in handy.
If you are able to track by
putting a special device,
like what Geotab has.
Those devices have ability
to-- they are sensors,
and they have the
ability to not only store
the various parameters.
They can find out if the
driver was rash, if there
were some potholes on the road.
So all of that can be
used to either incentivize
a particular set of users
in a particular zip code.
And obviously there
are privacy concerns,
so a lot of this thing is
generalized and offered
as a different model.
And this pricing
model is actually
disrupting the
insurance industry.
Another example in
the service industry
is benchmarking as a service.
So obviously when
you are collecting
all this kind of data--
reliability data from products
where the sensors are talking,
and how you are
consolidating feedback
to the product manufacturers.
And this data and
predictive insights
can be provided to others
in the same industry
or in other industries as
well, and this benchmarking
helps in future
product development
and also provides
competitive insights.
So that's the service industry.
Let's talk about smarter cities.
I don't know about you,
but I feel that the cities
are getting crowded.
We need to do something
about it, right?
And as per some studies
done by United Nations,
we will see a upsurge
in city population
over the next 50 years,
and resources in cities
would be constrained a lot.
Now how do we make sure
that these resources are not
being wasted?
So the heart of the possible
is at the intersection
of IoT and ML, and how
do we change the world
by improving the life of
common people like us?
So how do we make
these cities better?
Again, we talked about sensors
and interconnected IoT devices.
So there's real-time
monitoring that
can happen powered by
Cloud Analytics and ML.
Now this is some way whereby
city planners can get data
about the city's
roads, and they can
find out which roads are
congested in real time,
and devise mechanisms to
alert and divert traffic.
They can find out utilities.
Utilities can find out
from the sensors what
pipes are about to leak,
and thereby instead
of fixing the
problem, you can send
preventive crews ahead of time.
So on and so forth.
So structure health is covered.
There is fire safety things,
and also about air pollution.
So all in all, this
is something which
we are very passionate about,
and our client here, Geotab,
is also venturing
into smarter cities.
So I hope this
presentation has given you
an idea of the potential
of predictive maintenance.
The industry examples
and the demo we showed
gives you a bird's eye view
of how IoT sensor data can
be used with machine
learning, and how
they are using it today.
And they are looking at
building a better world
with smarter manufacturing,
smarter services, and smarter
cities.
So we will hang around for
some questions towards the end,
and thank you very
much for coming here.
There are some resources at the
back of this deck you'll find.
I'm inviting you to
the IoT track showcase
as allows it to springML
booth in Moscone West.
1338 is the booth number.
Please swing by.
And of course, all
four of us are here
if you would like to
swing by and talk,
and have your questions.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]